thank right moving on apologies restless
all we I think we've got counselor
burden and what would you the other
substitutes or counseling Pearson and
counts the mountain and the substitute
members we know B's counselor must kill
four counts of a person and counselor
mrs. Mason or Toby mountain okay moving
on to the minutes of meeting held on the
11th of June
can I take those as read I believe
everybody has a chance to reason read
the written answers sorry I'm quite a
folder can I just raised the issue about
the fact of the review of comitia
supposed to be chaired by a member of
the opposition
I don't understand to the vice chairman
but I don't know if it's appropriate so
has there been a ruling on this a long
time would say it but while this has
happened numerous times in the past when
you have been in your teeth and this is
never been raised and I have been the
vice chairman I would suggest at least
half a dozen times
well I'm actually stood up as I said to
stand out to become chairman happy that
they're looking right before and I'm
telling you think going from memory
there have ever been any issues of me
being not fair and scrupulous about the
way the meeting was conducted I talked
about never would suggest your I think
you're a very fair and very scrupulous
if I could say the word how it's an
issue about the Constitution whether
that's appropriate
I'm having for an office absolutely
wrong and it has been raised before
yeah and it's um custom and practice
that the vice-chairman standing for the
chairman so ok
oh no I'm sorry custom and practice or
the Constitution Constitution is over
allies customer practice the
Constitution just says the chairman has
from the opposition yeah but it doesn't
say anything about the vice chairman and
vice-chairman is pointed by counsel and
in the event of the Chairman not being
in attendance the vice chair booth again
stepped up but therefore he's acting as
chairman and he's been met with
opposition defector well you've got a
choice either I stay as chairman but
will suspend the meeting until we get a
ruling
it's quite simple or you can have an
alternative chairman no we we can't just
gone down this road you've got a choice
either as acting chairman and vice
chairman as far as I'm concerned if this
is the normal procedure normal practice
now has been for many years and as I've
said that like I've been in this
position for many years if this becomes
a major issue and we'll just suspend the
making Terry what one Chairman it was
the point of having a nice chain if you
can't stand in for the chairs and number
two it's that we're talking about the
position of chairman of the meeting if I
could ever be listened to
we talked about the position at the
middle of the meeting not we talked
about the chairman of the actual meeting
not necessarily the chairman of every
meeting because that's not going to
happen now because sometimes the
Chairman will not be there so it's the
position of chairman that is the
important thing as far as the
Constitution is concerned not
necessarily who cares the meeting and if
you have a vice chairman clearly that
implies they will chair the meeting when
the Chairman is not there that is a
matter of facts and it happens for every
other meeting in every other place that
I've ever been to
okay so the captain or saying but I
don't think we need some clarity in this
in the Constitution so certainly this is
not person and it's a matter of a
question of something that's written
down and doesn't seem to be applied as
one would expect I said that on every
other meet at meeting the vice chairman
steps up in every other meeting there
was a conservative clear and flashy
chair so it's not a melon
I have receipts to help you subtitle I
would really advise you on this
counselor this is amazing
this is not the first time I've been put
in this position it has never been
raised in the previous three or four
years over which if I have been involved
in the review committee off and on when
this situation has arisen I think the
only thing we can do is if you're
prepared to accept these things chairman
the moment we will pass this down to it
I want to say an officer or legal
department and ask for their views on it
in due course
yeah I think you're quite happy tests it
okay as long as they also whatever is
decided can be written into the
Constitution so there's a clarity of it
thank you Starscream
the review committee looked at the
Constitution very they didn't think it
wasn't raising notifier father it was on
the working party action
it wasn't raising this meeting I wasn't
here when it was presented so Carlson
well we'll get his clarification but in
the meantime so as the person who raised
it will just come back and just say I'm
happy for that to be the case
I heard what mr. Gale said and I do
understand from what he just said but it
has been raised previously there's been
what was happening I thought the game
for the ruling and for it to be looks in
the Constitution I understand the
Constitution - no on the game project
anyway right okay anything else no right
some receive declarations of interests
depending okay well this is one of the
insults we see three in a year very
amazing how your review
right Springs said this is one of three
reports that reviews each year this
final report for 1819 a summary of the
year-end position and so their committee
is off context
the council's income from its treasury
management activities during 1990 and
the increase excused the higher value of
cash balances an ounce of power driver
that period and also increasing the
average interest rate paid on the
investments the reports themselves
slightly more detail the investment
performances over the course of the year
in the interest rates that we received
online from those investments and that
set out in paragraph three point four
and the graph which shows how our
interest rate zones and trap to the base
rates from Bank of England which went up
for them in August 2013
counselors might also like to note the
broth at four point three which shows
the amount of investments the council
had two outstanding over the course of
the year as well I think the report is
reasonably self-explanatory so I wasn't
going to say a huge amount more in terms
of detail at this stage but if members
have any questions and I'm happy to try
honestly yeah well sure the rules
thank you think graph along one three
can you spray the difference between the
two is you've got average some
investment in fact that's outstanding
what exactly is that
and so the investments the average some
investments is it implies is the average
is invested over the course of that
month whereas the investments
outstanding shoshone amounts
in particular point jinked in point to
time so the blue line is harder than the
red why is the average the red that much
lower and because that starts the yearly
amounts and invested when lava sites or
brings the average done at any point in
time competin was actually listed at
that point in time because we have been
going after in here all right
or going to be those not planets
computing well I can take that way in
the future ports we can then make that a
bit more clear in terms of
differentiation between the lines of
that something
yeah I think I understand the mice mice
coming from is is there any way that
perhaps some of these phrases could be
put into more language I mean that's a
nuts and bolts view you're producing
things on a financial basis assuming
that we're all accountants okay most of
us so long well you try yeah I've tried
to make it clear Slovakia council mr.
Tyson Thank You mr. chairman
I think Elsa Lucas kids got very fat at
a point I don't think it's the
terminology I think we would understand
what an average is and I'm sure
absolutely skill does but what you're
not showing is the average over the
period of the graph and that's where the
the presentation needs to be altered
what you have here and he's quite right
to raise it is that we've got an amount
outstanding then you're showing an
average and that average could be over
any period but it should logically be
over the period that you're showing the
investments outstanding or if it's over
a longer period then you should show the
amounts over that period it should
relate so I think what we have here is
rather confusing information I do think
that should be taken away corrected and
I think it should be brought back to
this committee
showing what period that average is over
because obviously not over the average
that you're showing
well that's I like that they dig all
could be fair and group do we need this
people back that before the next routine
financial review yeah okay thank you
I don't think I accepted the
presentation it could be a bit narrow
but I don't think it alters this would
the meaning or the understanding of the
overall report and when will this be
presented to full council sorry excuse
to go to their next all cancel I believe
one sixteenth of your life so you think
the two guys so is there any chance lady
okay
so if we're not happy with the
explanation we can raise it and at the
full council that's research Chairman's
make it simple with it explanation
coachable counselors work yeah yeah or
bill people be prepared to to clarify
every issue gets released okay sorry
compositing drinks there's just a couple
of two or three persons probably the
first one is about the return obviously
not just its compact to 32,000 for the
Year office in four point four on page
six point three is slightly increase
which due to the higher value of cash
bonuses held by counsel of an increase
in average interest rates paid in
investments is it possible to have a to
give us a the actual return on
capitalist percentage or return on
investments as a percentage because the
beginning of the codes we had four
million and at the end of the period we
had nearly 12 million is probably just
pretty like to know either how much was
true exactly how much was due to the
increase in capital that we've got from
depository invested and how much was
true to higher than the expected
interest rates that could be done by of
what we were expecting to get present
case what we did get
don't be happy too that two-seaters up
or down but the magnet looks like we're
getting considerably more but a lot
without I think the majority of it it's
probably due to the increased
investments but I'm not sure every
interest rate that was cheap half
percent increase in the base rates of C
being reflected during the course of the
year but it doesn't go through to them
how much eg how much they know six is
due to the increase in troops the
increasing yeah they're actually
budgeted fifty so they were already
expecting to that's that one the other
one is and really they're not made to
these two them the other one is four
point two the fixed rate investments are
they long-term Holdings or they just
I've probably about a month or less in a
cylinder and under a year and germinate
the average time I believe that's really
thank you okay anybody got anything else
end of the recommendation under Section
eight you can see results
recommended contents of these people
so subject to clarification
does everybody so you like popping oh
yeah right okay through these all right
the first ones planning enforcement plan
that was on there last month then these
dudes be made by the portfolio holder
later in the month the next ones 819
national cultural services strategy
that's going to the executive and the
final one than the only new one can it
really be Christmas coming up um the
suspension of parking charges on
Saturdays before Christmas
the annual one that comes on and that
should be the decision will be made the
end
yep Oh take it away
the omentum is that you decided on last
month I'm trying to plan in to the
forthcoming meetings I managed to get
the update on recycling waste for the
third of September I would hope that I
might be able to get the council's use
of singing use plastics on there as well
although that might be spread a little
bit because talking to my colleagues
will be a very short report if we just
stick to single-use plastics so we might
expand it to Hale gray in the
territories yeah and do it that way
right the other ones I've got a plan in
as we go I have a difficulty with the
asset strategy in the fact that it's
already gone or going out to procurement
it's on the Official Journal of the
European Union so the spec is already in
there with the design trying to sort
that out
so can we just oh where do we go what
have you got a information
your next meeting is update on recycling
and waste and possibly council use of
single-use plastics although as I say
all probably September
yes September you know it's an exciting
yeah we fella premiums things like I've
written all this because that's a
routine one yes you'll see I'll put
Ripper in for October that okay and
tripping management mid-year review
notes about those members and then we've
just the final bit about the ICT review
whether any further members were going
to be added to that and as far as I'm
aware nobody is shown any interested in
joining their group so we stay as
constituted okay
your on that bottom yet yes optic
confirmed to me that I'm so nervous
as they are completes the agenda for the
meeting